So I have to ask you,
does Tom talk about Ufos all the time,
but you know he's not in the band.
No.
Yeah,
I know.
But you know,
always do that.
He always did.
We used to get loaded and just look out the bus window for one.
And I used to do it with him as like,
I don't know,
it's kind of a bonding experience.
It's like if you wanted to show me bow and arrows,
whatever were on tour together,
if forest had sit there and like,
you know,
check it out.
So with Tom,
that was his thing.
Like fucking let's get high and look for Ufo here.
We just sit there and like stare out the bus window,
look at ufs or like he would even go as far as when we're on tour,
like let's go and fucking look for bigfoot,
whatever it was,
you know,
and he would assemble a crew and they would go do it.
Oh I got ever got me on one of those trips cause that was just two fairy tale
for me.
But,
um,
but I would,
you know,
I'd do that.
And he was always,
it's really not something he just got into from the day I fucking met him.
He was obsessed with Ufos and aliens and was always very passionate about it to
the point where like,
I didn't know enough to,
to have any kind of,
I guess like opinion on it.
I was just very open and,
and you know,
just took it all in,
but nothing has changed.
He's still,
the other day I talked to him,
he's like,
I'm on the way to the fucking White House,
Bro.
And I don't ask any questions.
I had to be like,
as you should be,
you know,
whatever.
Let's fucking go.
Yeah.
What a great response.
Good luck with that.
Yep.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
he was a trip man.
Having a conversation with him was very strange because I'm,
a part of me was like Skype putting me on like,
what is happening?
He's dead ass house.
Deta seemed like it.
And we would look at these videos that were so clearly horse shit and he would
be like,
amazing.
Right?
And they're like,
what?
Like you think that that's an actual Ufo?
Like that is the fake fucking video I've ever seen in my life.
But he didn't see that at all.
Yeah.
In his mind,
he was seeing a real alien spaceship.
Even on tour.
I'd be like,
you'd walk in my room and he'd be like,
what are you doing?
And I'm like,
I'll check this thing out.
I just made up whatever,
playing drums.
He'd be like,
dude,
fucking whatever.
George Bush just did.
You know,
he needs just coming at me with something like politics.
He's been watching CNN or,
or,
yeah.
Like he's just,
he's always been obsessed with it.
So he's obsessed with all sorts of like hidden things like not just your foes,
but big foot two and conspiracy theories,
politics,
everything.
Very,
very passionate about all those things.
Conspiracy theories and politics.
It's an interesting how those things go together because people who are always
wondering like,
who the fuck is running things and what's really going on?
What's happening behind the scenes?
Who's pulling the strings?
What is it all really mean?
Yeah.
You know?
But the UFO thing,
it's like pool boy,
boy you got up.
I mean,
I absolutely believe there could be intelligent life out there,
but I'm seeing a fucking single thing that makes me think that anybody's got a
picture video.
Yeah.
I feel like it could,
it could be real.
I believe,
but I'm not,
I can't fucking,
I'm not dedicating my life to search for it,
you know,
and I,
I give it to a man to like,
honestly to walk away from your fucking very successful band to go do that shit.
Like I have nothing but respect for his passion,
but it's like I couldn't do that.
That's insane.
Yeah.
It's like that just,
it really shows like he's,
you know,
he's very,
very passionate about it.
And you'll be saved up some money.
Yeah,
me too.
You know a Survivorman Les Stroud.
Nah,
he's a,
you ever seen that show?
Fucking great show.
He,
uh,
would survivorman would go out into the woods with our limited amount of things.
He would say like,
okay,
I've got this bucket,
I've got a fucking pocket knife,
a and I got a ball,
a ball of yarn.
And I'm going to survive out here for seven days.
And it,
and he films the whole thing and he'd be filming himself like eating frogs and
catching a squirrel and finding edible plants and just living out in the forest.
And oftentimes going days and days without food.
And then he would have like a point where he'd get rescued,
know seven days in,
there would be a spot where they would meet him.
Um,
he had an experience when he was in Alaska alarm time ago where he was camping
and he said he heard footsteps,
like big,
heavy footsteps.
And you heard some sound that sounded like a gorilla or something like that.
And,
uh,
and then it ran off.
And to this day he's convinced that that was a big foot.
And so now he has survivorman bigfoot and he goes out into the woods and just
looks for evidence of Sasquatch.
Oh,
he should.
He needs to.
It needs to hit up.
Tom.
Tom,
we pulled up,
he'll go with,
and he would love that.